Out of 10 were lot of ladies and gentlemen,
what's up?
It's hilarious.
He and the two of you guys together when you're shot,
when he told me he was your son,
first of all,
he instantly became my friend.
Second of all,
I was like,
what is it like having John Witherspoon as a dad?
That'd be crazy.
And mind you,
I only told you because he was asking me,
because I go to the clubs all the time,
hanging out in one.
Then,
you know,
just kicking it with friends and he said,
well,
who's at the club now take?
He's like,
he was telling you like JD who?
Who is it that a who's who to bring her?
They who?
The funny one who didn't want him to it and I'm like,
I was like,
I mean there's a bunch of them just like,
you know,
Brendan this.
Then I said Joe was always there.
He's got a bunch of people come to the show.
He's like Joe Rogan.
I know Joe.
That's my man.
My man.
We worked together when I was and he told me to say,
yeah,
I saw you.
I think was Caroline's in New York.
We were doing,
I was doing like the eight and you were doing a 10 or something like that to
show,
but it probably was on a Thursday.
You know,
you probably did.
Something was happening.
We are doing it close to each other a long time ago.
Long time ago.
Maybe.
Maybe 15 years ago.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
I haven't been there in the wild.
I work,
I haven't been in New York in a while.
I started going in New York.
It's a weird one.
If you done,
have you done Kevin Dunn,
Carolina touristy,
all tourists and foreigners feels like,
right?
Right in Times Square,
Yeah.
It doesn't feel like you're doing standup in New York.
Feels it feels weird.
It feels like what people want New York to be,
but they're from somewhere else.
Like a good percentage of them are wild.
Amala that's great.
Great Club.
Oh yeah.
They just,
you know,
it's different than the seller or you know,
danger fields is my favorite.
Joey Diaz was just down there and he said he did Dangerfield like five,
six nights.
I never did Dangerfield.
Nobody does Dangerfield?
No,
it's half full all the time.
It's amazing that they're still around.
They're still around.
Somebody's gotta be sound coke
all the time to keep that place like that.
Um,
but the name alone brought probably brings people in,
but it's an iconic place,
man.
Yeah.
I like New York.
I just haven't been back to since Letterman gone.
I don't go do his show anymore.
I hadn't been to Carolina and then about three years.
Four years.
But you,
you do a lot of clubs in the room while we were talking about 40,
40 some clubs.
Wow.
To clubs a year.
You know,
my agents come to my house in January and they tell me all the clubs I got that
year.
They changed what date we go over.
We go over hip at one.
All right.
June 15 June.
You're going to be in soon.
Y'All make the money be going get,
yeah.
Okay.
That's good.
Yeah.
That's the goal.
So we do 47 club.
I said,
man,
this is too much work.
Ain't been 52 weeks in a year.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
I got to have some time off.
What about me?
Yo worried about this money,
but when you have time off,
all you do is complain about not being on the road,
complaining about people telling me what to eat,
what to drink.
Oh my goodness.
I'd like to get me a little taste night.
The need little taste.
That's what I'm saying.
Everybody look,
keep the wolf off your back.
That's right.
So I give him,
he,
I get me a little tastes.
The real problem is that travel though.
That's what we're talking.
It's too much.
It's too little air travel over and over and over again.
And then we were freaking out about eight 37 and you were explaining to us that
yeah,
mostly they use them in overseas and some South Wales African countries and in
Asian country they use them.
Well,
they had like two planes that just got lost,
right.
One from Malaysia.
I think there's all pilot light and doing all that.
Lex Friedman is a software engineer and uh,
he's,
he specializes in AI as a professor at Mit.
And he was explaining to me,
it's basically the software glitch was making it nose dive.
Yeah.
That's not,
that's not something I would want to hear.
I when I paid 2100 800 to get my seat.
If you're a software engineer,
you have to,
you would have to up the pilot or a copilot to let them know like,
hey,
someone has to,
obviously they all know what they're doing in the cockpit,
but does someone know what to do with the computers going down?
Like it's a really good question.
Do they have any training in how to reboot computers or,
or is there a bypass or a work around for the computers?
LEX does.
Artificial intelligence is mostly what he does.
He works on like cars,
autonomous cars and planes and stuff.
And he was talking about as these things get more and more updated,
you just have glitches happen.
Happens all the time with your phone.
Right?
You get a,
a new bug and Twitter just crash on you all the time and they release an update.
But if you're on a fucking plane,
you,
what are you doing?
Yeah.
And how do you react?
What does it mean?
How do you react?
Wow.
You'd have to go through a flight simulation.
It's scary.
There's a bug in the plane.
Here we go,
run over all that software before they put it on a plane.
You know they had um,
the plane that crash.
What was the last plane?
Crack.
That was where in Africa,
I dunno,
there was two.
One was was one.
Russia?
No,
Russia.
I think it was an Africa.
Anyway,
those pilots are trained to the end.
They to the hilt.
They train new pilots,
but they don't know themselves.
Some of the guys who was training to people,
what the heck's going on?
It was a pilot that was off work that was on the plane just before this plane
crash.
Same plane.
They had trouble before and he came out of his seat and went up to the cockpit
and the cockpit and,
and say the plane.
She knew what to do.
He'd only want to know what to do on a plan B in that fucking plane.
Looking down the aisle and watching that guy walk into the,
what are you doing?
I pick a no,
you don't see no one.
They they protect that though.
They put the food cart in front of the yeah.
Yeah.
Food caught stopping.
Anybody now they got a bolt on the door.
Those,
all those doors you had the cockpit pilot is in the bathroom taking a booboo.
Yeah.
That's what that they don't have their own pilots bathroom.
No.
No Nigga we can fit it.
Can't fit on a plane.
Blocked the area.
Ready to put that full card dance.
He has seen that many times.
That's a weird move.
I don't you have like a dedicated thing for it.
Why is the food cart yeah.
The thing you don't,
you have like a shit of a gate.
Someone called leap that right.
Should have another door.
Just like the guide on the carpet.
Yeah.
They should have like some like uh,
like you know they had do the one of those metal gates in front of those doors.
Windows.
Yeah.
One of those click,
clamp it down where they knew that didn't work because they had the riot in
[inaudible] 66 and they told all them down.
Oh,
the gates on the,
Oh yeah,
I remember that.
I was watching them guide.
Something's due to the loc that fucking flew open.
Yeah.
What could you do to stop someone from bum rush in the cockpit?
Those flight attendants are not going to stop.
No,
no hill.
Well,
they should probably prepare planes with a flight attendant who has training
like that in the future,
like a female or male who's job that's too much with money.
Too much money.
Do it.
That's your private security.
The pilot is locked in the bathroom.
The other pilot and the store,
this is locked in the India booth where they fly the plane so you ain't getting
in there anyway,
I guess.
Yeah.
Unless when the pilot come up to the bathroom,
then he's not when he opened the door,
but they got other guys got,
the students got to come out.
He got to go in.
It's just too complicated.
Now being the people that's sitting down going to know what's happening.
Again,
going to jump up.
I know somebody this,
that's chaos on a plane.
If you start seeing all that that you're talking about,
well don't you think turbulence?
Chaos.
I was on a plane once.
Two dudes almost got into a fight.
The lady stopped serving them.
One guy was Paul,
he was putting his luggage in a spot above another dude's hat.
And the guy said,
that's from my stuff.
And he said,
no,
get whoever gets there first is the one that gets it.
And he's like bullshit.
And he's like grabbing his arm and like,
you know,
like physical for a second.
I had a,
um,
you know,
I took my bag off to get some out of my bed.
I,
I'm on the plane first.
Some guy walked past me and shit.
Okay.
And then you look up [inaudible] he gonna put it,
hey bro,
she ain't back yet.
That go on up there.
He said,
well shoot,
it headed up,
down.
I looked at this shocking.
He chose Shiree sure.
And he got in his seat and he's sitting next to me too.
Oh for the whole flight.
He ain't shit man man.
Get the hell out of my way.
Take that crap out of here.
He thought I was a crazy man.
I forgot.
Huh?
I wasn't tough.
I get that.
No I wouldn't.
I'm on the plane is full now.
Yeah.
He one seat next to me open.
He gonna put this stuff down.
I'm going to get my stuff.
Trying to find my earphones
punk with putting stuff up there in front of boy.
You could just come in.
They have to place for you above my head.
I'm in my bag.
You don't think that's my day cause you were cause you were going through your
bag to put their stuff up there looking for my thing.
People just look for an opportunity to be a dick.
Yeah.
I think
planes are the closest that people get to walking.
That emulates road rage.
Yeah.
The line.
Yes.
It's the closest thing.
Like when people get up and they get up too soon and then like they're pushing
forward already and you're like,
come on man.
Let everybody get up in the line.
Some people like Naya push through.
Yeah,
I was,
I was at the gas station just now and you know how they have the big oil
tankers,
they have to bring the gas to the gas station.
They were blocking,
they were blocking in where people needed to go to park.
And the guy who was,
uh,
there was telling me that some lady was just there and she was mad at him cause
he pulled in a few minutes after she parked to get gas in the car and he was
saying that,
uh,
she was like,
you're blocking me and he's like,
lady,
I am either going to block you in or I'm blocking the street.
I can't block the full street with all the traffic.
And then by the time she was ready to go,
she finally was like nudging her way out of the gas station and the guy was
trying to help her and she's like,
don't help me.
I don't need your help mark.
And she's like,
and he said,
I'm sorry,
it's going to be a minute.
She's like,
I don't got a minute.
And then I asked him,
I was like,
what kind of car is he driving?
He was like,
he was like a range rover,
new new ranger.
I'm like,
oh,
she's got plenty of tasks.
So one guy put his seat
back before the plane took off.
You know,
you put and get comfortable here,
this seat all the way back into some crazy.
Hey Buddy.
Hey,
you cannot put your seat back before the plane get up in the air.
You see
got you guys on dude,
somebody's leg.
I got the back of the chair on someone's getting said buddy,
I had been doing this for 20 and 30 years.
Yeah,
I don't give a fuck what you been doing.
You cannot do it today.
They got into a spat.
Oh Man,
I got into passengers to passengers.
That's what my was one passenger plane cop.
Cop.
Yeah.
There's,
there's videos of that all the time though.
I remember I saw one,
uh,
one of them out here leaving like a,
or coming into or leaving Burbank and uh,
it was like two guys who either the plane just landed or they were just about
takeoff and got into a full fist fight over mind you as a southwest flight over
a seat that didn't belong to anyone,
you know,
because over there at that airport,
they're probably going from Burbank to Vegas.
And then dude was like,
hey man,
I'm taking a seat.
No,
no,
that's mine.
And the next thing you know,
it's,
it's a,
it's a fight in between the idol and it's crazy that they serve you boots on the
plane.
You can get drunk at the airport,
you can get calls,
a drug,
and that drug is everywhere.
There's flying.
As he set up,
it's 100% set up and
bring any alcohol through security.
Know that we usually look on secured,
we gonna use alcohol.
Yeah,
it's hilarious.
And they'll pour that stuff brother.
Then they get Dick,
they all know me on the plane,
so they give me a bottle of the goal.
You think of man,
just the wooden spoon had wrap it up in a towel.
I can tell what I,
I'm like I'm gonna sneak out of here with this big as bottle.
I do it.
I put her in there.
Fuck it man.
I get it.
You know,
you know they don't want like liquid bombs or some shit.
They don't want you to bring in some no.
Yeah,
right it,
I got it.
It's true.
I wish that wasn't something you ever had to think about.
But if it happens once every few years,
it's enough that you gotta have to think about it.
Yeah.
You know I had unit can't have ounces,
three ounces liquid in your bay,
so I had a three ounce bottle of my expensive Cologne,
but I use half of it so I ain't got no three hours.
I got,
I got one and a half now we can take the whole thing.
Got You.
Okay Michael on that come calling me about Brianna dollars,
sir.
I'm taking $150 just go cause you got,
they took my colognes.
You spray it on yourself before getting on one more pumped in road.
I spray this on everybody else too.
That was,
that was,
but they serious about that.
Yeah.
Some dude's still rock Cologne.
I work alone heavy.
I like,
oh,
I get it from Bergdorf Goodman.
I get this stuff.
She,
I grew up,
it was a lot of pimps around the neighborhood and they wore the best cologne.
Them dudes was shot on a heavy,
heavy,
shiny.
No,
no,
and he hit him.
Say it like this.
So when I got older,
that's what I would do.
I get clone.
Like
smacking yourself.
Yes.
Pimps used to crack me up,
but it would be so sharp.
Yeah.
Shoes be so shiny and they get that Cologne.
You smell me talking to him.
He felt that boy smell good.
I'm broke.
I got about 3 cents in my pocket and holes on the bottom of my shoes and then
pimps be at the end,
felt like,
yeah,
he's going to be out on a Monday.
Just hang out again and keep doing what you're telling them.
Keep doing what you're doing.
Oh boy.
UFC pimps up hoes down.
Yo.
Yeah,
I know.
What's your name?
Real life.
It's like,
you know,
weird light.
It's up.
It isn't some clowns.
They like clowns.
They get there who get together and they,
they sweat.
They do.
That's what,
and that's where he lived.
I used to be around 12th Street.
You know,
you're the one in Detroit.
You Do,
you know I'm not well street,
uh,
black bottom.
They called one place called black bottom.
Hasting Street.
All pimps and hoes.
They had them big old had on and they didn't have back then,
they didn't have high heel shoes on.
You know them,
what do you call it?
Yeah.
Detroit was booming.
Oh yeah.
Detroit fell off quicker than any city in the western world in terms of like,
it was the richest city in the world.
They white of the card.
Yeah.
Motor city.
Because the people,
the factories closed,
the factories closed.
People had put their money into the house.
The car factory money.
Yeah.
They get that loan because you've got that.
You've been here 15 years,
you're getting a good records,
you've got a good things,
they give you a car and give you an a and a home.
But when that's like a failed board and people,
oh my God,
what am I gonna do?
What am I gonna do?
What caused it?
Do you know?
I mean obviously I threes move manufacturing,
moving to Mexico and other countries,
all that stuff.
People have been to that for themselves.
Yeah.
But in remoters full it him themselves.
But a lot of companies are still there.
It's just the nine just to bend them.
But like a lot of car companies,
you know,
like Ford,
right?
Gentleman,
not like it used to be GM Pratt gives you,
they're still there,
but they're there in a much more limited role.
But it's their own,
like the,
the,
the what like the base or kind of like a warehouse or maybe they moved that to,
maybe they're,
you know,
that show top gear.
Yeah,
they do a new show called the grand tour.
They do it on Amazon and they did one episode where they went to Detroit and uh,
they were in Detroit.
They bought a house for like two grand.
Oh yeah.
You get a whole house,
so you get $6,000 six to that I think too,
that can whole house like a house house.
You could live in it like,
yeah.
Oh yeah.
It wasn't a bad house.
It needed some work.
But everybody moved.
But nobody's there.
But he's gone.
Everybody that the,
when we were there when we drove through,
it was like the amount of giant warehouses that are completely empty with all
the shattered windows.
It's very depressing.
It's very weird.
It's coming back.
And I was,
yes,
there two months ago,
I,
and my brother had died.
I went to his funeral and uh,
we drove around.
I couldn't find my grandfather's house.
They told that shit now,
boy,
you know,
they had somebody burned it down,
some of the stuff like that.
But it was,
it was just like any other city.
To me,
it's coming back for sure.
And let's also like,
you know,
there's a lot of young businesses are starting up and craft businesses and you
know,
even there's enough people around people of ingenuity,
they figured out a way.
It's just not going to be what it used to be,
Ben.
And it's whole new ballgame now.
It is a new ball game.
New People,
these people that are young.
My son wasn't in Alexandra.
Alex,
he's,
how old is he?
2123 he,
he loved choice.
He never seen this man.
We were downtown Detroit on Saturday night,
warm hot night.
People walking around and he's beautiful women walking around there.
Elegant.
My son went crazy.
They
go back to Detroit.
We don't,
well we don't go there.
And you're from there.
We don't,
we,
we just don't go to where his family's from a lot.
So it's one of those things where family gone,
hey,
you got something.
You got relatives,
you don't know them.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
my brothers,
I don't know my brother's daughters [inaudible] his brother.
Neither does Alex and me.
That's why Alex is more inclined to his nieces.
Oh my God.
Did they loved him.
And they,
uh,
they walked around and I said,
look,
I'm going back to the hotel.
I was getting too much harassment.
So I said,
I'm going back to the hotel.
So I hold the jar.
I told the driver,
take me back.
They can jump out,
you can pick them up later.
And they've got a ride.
So they got back to the hotel about two,
three hours later.
But I was sleeping by the end all.
But Detroit is nice when I was there,
I'm telling you,
man,
Detroit was nice.
Yeah,
I did the Fox theater and it's so old that they have these pillars in the wall
that are stained from cigarettes.
No click a like a darkish orangeish stain just from nicotine.
That's great to have a beautiful home,
a beautiful theater.
Beautiful Theater.
Yeah.
They had to replace one of the pillars,
one pillar that was clean.
And then the other pillars you go,
whoa,
that's cigarette smoke.
And you get to really see it.
And everybody saying that,
Frank Sinatra get it.
Everybody got their signature all over the place.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I put my,
I put my senior down by 20 times.
Yeah,
I've been there about eight times.
It's a great player watching Jim stations down here.
Oh Wow.
Temptations.
Frankie Lymon and the teenagers.
That was a long time ago,
but beautiful,
beautiful place.
Oh,
the other place torn down the Olympia stadium where they used to play and scene
in a piston.
He used to play basketball there.
They all,
they tore that place.
Now that's all I was presently there.
Elvis Presley love kid.
And I saw Elvis.
I was wanting to go to see the Kronk gym,
but I think they tore that down.
I used to play basketball at the crunch gym.
Really?
They see you used to be,
he used to be a basketball court there.
Then they tore,
it might've torn it down now,
but they had,
they built boxing rings around there.
All the boxes where we played ball,
they've got boxing around that.
And I went up there one day with my shoes.
I thought,
what the hell happened here?
They didn't close the doors and everything turned into journey to boxing.
Not even bake great boxes,
wasn't Tommy Hearns and then people came out of the shore.
Lennox Lewis and then he'll steward steward was there head coach there before so
he died.
Yeah.
There wasn't a amazing champion.
It was white.
One of those places is a few places where you want to go.
Like when you're in La,
you want to go to wild card.
You just want to say you've been there.
I want to go to the cage.
You when you counted take time.
Anytime.
We'll tell me knocked the crap.
Let me know anytime you want to go.
There's going to be fires in California.
Look through the the screen like this
mother fucker.
Oh Man,
we can get you pretty close.
Oh yeah,
you're right up there.
We get real close with tickets to this boy.
I can't believe that he had dude.
I did.
Yes.
That's as you got to knock the fuck out.
That really serious about that.
I only ever gone to one of them live.
No,
no,
never.
Never.
No.
Yeah,
let's hook that up.
Oh my filming.
I stay ready.
I'll be like,
so what are your feelings about the fight?
Almost set up a tripod in front of him.
Oh my God.
Just react straight.
I see it on TV.
Go pro or something.
Oh yeah.
Don't go pro and Benji
and eat it.
I love it when they do a little update on their background.
They do a piece on the background.
As soon as I saw one,
this guy was within within Lufkin.
Oh,
he talking about,
well,
whenever,
whenever I whip your ass,
I want your wife to come home and clean my house.
I won.
I want,
I want her to come and cook me a meal and she cook anything.
I wanted to cook me.
This dude's on me.
Did He,
this guy was a resilient,
the guy that opponent,
he said,
well man,
come on man.
Do you,
you don't have to be,
that's just this play in this fight and you ain't got to talk about my wife and
stuff,
man.
You don't tell me what to do to this Italian or something.
The [inaudible] son,
his name is,
we are resilient as Anderson Silva.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Peas own and one guy.
Oh,
he's about 43 Anderson's innocence.
40 tail might be a little older than that.
Yeah.
Anderson's greatest middle weight of all time.
First round.
This boy put his foot up.
Okay.
What the fuck are you talking about?
The one where his ingles snapped.
Are you talking about that one?
Are you talking about something or are we talking about kicked out different
when he's talking about kicking them in this,
it was a fight,
but I never seen a foot come up that quick and that and it tolls.
Hitting the motherfucker.
Did
I say I ain't never seen nothing like this.
Oh,
and boy,
that boy did.
I did.
Fell asleep.
I think you're thinking of a different fight now.
Thinking of a v tour.
Vito Belfort,
Anderson.
So within,
within,
within.
Yeah,
and he run in his,
that's the guidance.
That's the front kick to the face.
One that's like a legendary kick.
The other one was chill son Michel son in one.
He kicked him and then he dropped him.
They need him to the body and took them out with punches.
Unbelievable.
How did the Mike,
this unbelievable how he can work that foot.
How do you feel about your son's impression of you?
It's really good.
You know,
he doesn't think it sounds like him at all.
He doesn't,
uh,
w well here I only know it because this is how he talks to me all the time.
He'll just be like,
um,
GED.
No.
What'd you,
what'd you,
what'd you do in a day you got work,
you got to go well,
shit back and talk to all them people hat.
I never eat all,
all the noises like he's,
he's,
he be a,
you'd be perfect for Amr.
We should just make that type of stuff like him,
him just breathing.
I was in line at the airport coming from,
I think I was in
Saint Louis or something like that.
And so I'm behind his lady [inaudible] two or three people in front of her and
I'm behind her.
So I'm,
I backed them weight,
making my little noise.
She was back,
she will like an old,
Old Lady,
Tina woman,
Spanish woman.
And she looked back and she went back,
back to looking forward.
And then fee.
I said,
no Mama,
well
mine,
I don't care.
Whatever
she say,
you make a lot of noise.
Wow.
She's a,
you make a lot of noise sir.
I don't remember making any noise.
That's what
you do when you got in the car today,
you got in the car and you
[inaudible] got to express myself.
It's noises and noises and questions.
Those are,
those are his like the moment you get in the car [inaudible] you see what
happened,
how,
how far we got to go to get the joke we and they were driving 30 miles an hour.
He's like,
then you're going to face,
don't you think?
Let's do a
little quick little quick on the,
on the freeway.
I'm like worth more on the freeway is 60 mile.
I'm going slower.
No,
his voice,
his voice is just like one of many I've come across cause I,
cause I do voiceover and all that stuff.
So it's one of those things where I'm lucky enough to have that one in my back
pocket because sometimes I'll throw it out there and people that I'd be like,
I don't know.
A lot of people do a John Witherspoon impression.
It's interesting.
That's a practice on that.
Yeah,
man.
It's gotta be nice though.
Seeing him get into show business,
getting into stand up.
I guess so.
You like it?
Yeah.
He's funny.
He,
I don't know.
I came from 11 kids,
11 kids.
So hope you'd be successful.
I'm going to try my best to be successful.
He's too busy counting his coins to worry about my [inaudible].
God bless us.
O God bless us all.
You're on your own.
Good luck.
But I mean,
oh he's,
you know,
he's supportive,
but he's one of those guys were,
uh,
cause I didn't want to do entertainment at all when I was younger.
I wanted to,
I wanted to do art.
Then when I was drawing,
I used to go to college and then I didn't know how to turn art into a career.
So,
uh,
one of my friends like,
why don't you try acting?
You always wasting time in class making us laugh.
And I was like,
oh,
that's interesting idea.
So I started like doing commercial liked and whatnot.
But,
uh,
I have friends who are comics,
like I don't usually bring up,
he's my dad.
Like it's something that just randomly happens usually like,
uh,
and when that comes across they're like,
oh,
that's crazy.
So you've got like a well of information in the sense of being a good comic and
writing and this and that.
I'm like,
ah,
like not that I don't,
but it's just asking him questions about stuff like that is the funniest stuff
cause he's just very like,
like you just said,
is there,
it's very flat out and just kind of like,
oh yeah.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Be Funny.
Like,
how much more can you tell a guy though?
Really?
You just got to get your own,
you know,
we were talking about that last.
All right.
People ask me,
do you go to the clubs and looking at your sign and help him?
Right.
Hell No.
He won't.
He doesn't.
I featured for him and,
uh,
he doesn't watch my set.
Like I just go up and I do,
I do my time and I come into the Korean room,
I'm like,
Hey,
you ready to go?
And he's like,
oh yeah.
Oh,
they sound like they were laughing.
So sounded like you did all right.
I'm like,
yeah man,
there's a father to do
any criticism,
any pointers or anything?
Huh?
You ever give him any pointers?
Eight tips.
Mehta be funny.
I'm,
I'm on.
I'm usually the one,
I'm the one on the opposite spectrum.
Giving him tips about like how he can,
how he can leverage like his,
you know,
his,
uh,
his notoriety in this day and age on the Internet.
That's my thing.
Ah,
so it's one of the things where like if I have a question about standup,
I'll ask,
but he doesn't,
you know?
Yeah.
You should definitely have a very active social media.
I help him run it.
So good.
Yeah.
Who's on there all the time?
Kevin Hart's always,
always,
here's the thing,
here's the thing.
Literally creating his social media was just a fluke because one day,
like five or six or seven years ago,
someone trended that he passed away.
And because of that,
we had to create social media for him.
So when that happened,
he's calling me and I'm getting calls from random people who know him.
And also my cousins,
like I got,
I got family call me crying.
Like is he okay?
Is Everything okay?
And he called me and he's like,
JD,
you gotta help me out some wrong on the internet.
They think I'm wrong.
He's saying,
Ma my,
all my,
all my family is calling me and I don't want to talk to them.
Like so.
So we created them a Twitter that day and then through Twitter I told him,
I'm like,
well just tell people you're around.
And we tweeted out like,
Hey y'all,
this is the real John Witherspoon,
blah blah blah.
I don't listen to those phone.
He's making up them rumors cause it was,
it was worldwide trending or whatever,
like Hashtag rip pops or something.
And then off of that is Twitter gained like 25 k and I'm like an hour.
And then later on down the road he got into Instagram kind of randomly where he
just,
uh,
he had an Instagram,
didn't really post.
And then I think one day you did,
you did just a random thing where he was ram choked you.
I talked to Megan and what's your name man?
Oh he was making,
he was making a joke about like bill Cosby and whatnot and he was like big
canvas where I'm with them that does stuff bill and whatever other social media
platforms randomly found it,
re posted it and now he's like,
he went from like six k to like 120 people following me.
I just don't do anything.
Yeah,
he doesn't understand like how social media is know there's like the future,
but I try to keep them in the loop.
It's a great way to avoid doing morning radio.
You don't like doing,
I hate
doing,
I get it.
I got to get up Friday morning,
I get to,
I get to Kansas City at 10 o'clock that night,
Thursday,
tomorrow night,
and then I had to get up Friday morning.
I don't know the time or anything like that yet,
but I probably do three or four radio stations.
Yeah,
that's what I'm talking about.
We take we,
they drive you and you're so sleepy.
Yeah,
I'm back over here and over here we're saying eat,
take a nap later and then you still kind of wrecked when the first show rooms.
You've got to do two shows.
So it's not fun and I'm,
I'm,
you know,
I'm slowing down,
but if you build up your social media,
you can cut that part of it hourly.
And I'm sure you have like relationships
with some those radio stations where you like them.
Oh,
you want to come in and do it?
That's cool.
If you want to do it,
but to have to do it,
they have to do it is half to do it in your sleep.
It's just nice.
It's not good for your brain.
And you can post like a story or on like on like it,
or you could post an Instagram video saying like,
Hey,
I'm going to be here this weekend.
Bill Bellamy.
Oh yeah.
Cut.
Cut It in half.
Cut the time in half.
You don't have to do that.
Get up in the morning stuff,
but they want to see me.
Yeah.
These Radio Djs,
right.
Is there anyone that she pops,
they want to see pops.
Oh Man.
Coming in.
That's,
I ain't no damn leg and I needed some money and that's why I'm a comic.
I'm go out and work all the time cause I need money.
Definitely explain that.
Cause I did have a question when I first started doing standup and I was like,
Hey dad,
I'm from uh,
from a motivational standpoint.
I was like,
Hey dad,
what,
what got you in the standard?
What is it that like motivated you to want to do it?
He looked at me and say motivated me.
Oh,
I was broke.
He was like,
I was broken.
Someone told me I was funny until I went to California and got on stage and just
started making dollars.
I was like,
so then what are you doing here?
You don't even like this?
And he's like,
I mean it's like I do my thing,
you know,
I'm not a comic who just love to make people laugh relative.
What do you love?
Money
count that shape.
Oh.
Oh my God.
Let me tell you sometime sometime on the way home,
see if I had a good week though.
Some of them clubs pay a lot of damn money.
He paid over 30 some thousand dollars for six weeks,
six nights,
four,
I mean four,
six shows in a weekend.
And I don't count the money,
but when I do one nighters,
they,
you know,
they had to pay you half of the money up front and again,
give you money just before you go on stage.
So I have some at my head,
14 $15,000 in my pocket,
brother.
I'd be on that plane feeling that feeling,
that money,
glass of wine,
tall glass of that.
These are his passions.
These are his passion.
Prior to them having a good time and look at it and I begin to count,
I called it,
bake up America,
check out my account.
Four o'clock in the morning,
I punch in my theme punching isn't union.
You have your balance is [inaudible] De de de.
De.
That's so ridiculous.
We gotta get you gotta get to the APP.
We got to just get through this.
The Bank of America App.
You saved the phone call.
I don't man.
I bet.
To go through the motion hit you.
You like to hear it.
Tell him it's your last name and your social security number
and you'll put your balance is,
oh,
it's just so wonderful.
I was broken.
I was coming up,
man.
When did you start?
Huh?
Where'd you start doing standup?
Back in Detroit?
In Detroit.
I was,
um,
my brother used to go to acting class on Thursday and his wife,
I said,
well that's pretty cool.
I should try to be an actor.
So I got in the yellow pages,
they had him yellow page.
They don't have them now though.
You're awake.
I'd go through the phone and get the number,
but they had the yellow pages I go through.
I went to young patient and went to an acting class,
private acting lessons and I called the Guy,
he said,
$25 an hour.
Come on over.
We can get started.
So this teacher at John Pinkelman acting classes put in a comedy show once once
a year and you see,
I want you to be on the show was I don't want him about no comedy.
He said,
well you this was very lucrative business.
You can make a lot of money.
And so we really,
I wouldn't,
it stole the show.
Why is it,
wait a minute,
that's funny.
Timing stole the show.
I used to do impressions of Nike and Cole,
Johnny Mathis and uh,
wasn't boy Joe Cocker and all that stuff.
Oh,
Mick Jagger,
I used to Mick Jagger,
do you stoke,
go eat,
go,
go.
And they had about 500 people out there for the show.
I'm bouncing across the state like Joe Cocker.
Boy.
It was so funny.
And I got a standing ovation and I said,
wait,
am I could probably make some money doing this.
So I really was money money was your number one motivation when you borrow money
is,
you know,
tell him my love and affection as some little,
I didn't have that at my wish.
I didn't have that luxury.
No luxury.
Get out of my way so I can count this.
Where did you start out in la?
What clubs did you start out here?
Oh,
I drove from Detroit to La.
I moved to New York.
Um,
six 71.
1971.
I was about 30 years old,
29 30 and I went to material,
could be a fashion model.
I was passionate about Detroit,
really fashion commercials.
I worked at Cadillac Motorcar and,
and my job was plating bumpers,
these big fucking bumpers.
And so the bumpers,
I would need the money's,
I'm picking this up cause you know you use night using in Trillium and you
losing endorphins and everything else you got in your body to kick in and put
this big bump on this fucking line.
Do it to keep going and get into the plating pit.
So I have now that number going down and I headed my three minutes.
I look at his magazine,
I saw a gas stand next to a car.
I looked better than that dude.
Damn.
I went into the,
I went to the yellow pages again and got me a call.
The acting lady called the am Marlene schools.
They say,
oh sure,
come on in.
They gave me a job that weekend.
I thought I was hot.
I went to New York then do look 10 times better than me.
They tall off.
That's your motto.
See you.
I'm the midget model.
So I couldn't do that.
So I I uh,
I got the hell out of there.
I went back to you had went to New York.
I went down there,
stayed in New York three years back to La and I met but back to Detroit and got
a car and drove the de la by myself.
And when you went to La,
you went to do stand up?
Yeah,
I went to do acting in and stand up.
I cut that Molly.
Now I've never said that shit at work.
Where did you start out doing stand up here at the comedy store?
The store?
Yeah.
I was the first one that I was there with Mitzi.
Wow.
I will never,
Mitzi first started,
had to please Sammy and Mitzi breaking up.
Mitzi.
Sammy used to send me one of them the rules.
Sammy was big.
He was a big time common keep working for Frank Sinatra and Dean Martin Lawler.
He opening for them.
Mitzi needed somebody.
I needed a place,
so I'm,
I got a job.
Mission gave me a job as the MC left.
Dave Letterman was the MC,
the first show I mc the second show.
He didn't have no money then either.
He had a wife,
he had a red truck and a dog named Bob.
That's the only thing he came to la with and I just had this blue.
I had this blue Mustang I boat for about 150 to dry the l $850 car drove tail
all the way to la.
Wow.
You know,
I was determined to get out there and get me some of that money
leak.
All the transmission fluid.
I had to get up every 200 miles to feel the car backed up at all and
transmission fluid every 200 miles on the mouse.
I bet that nightmare you.
Oh,
oh.
You hear that shit and it's only only light.
You see headlights on the car at that point.
God,
I'm going to stick.
I had to stick with me and had a little fun and put that all in that car looking
around.
You know what?
I'd be doing it again
and got the California.
No,
I actually went to Las Vegas Person.
I'm fuck you got stuck.
I got stuck at alone.
He told me about that.
What happened?
That blew his money,
I guess to me.
I had a guy tell me how to keep this thing in front of your cute grab that.
Oh here.
Yeah man.
Tell me my friend,
he rich boy.
He said,
look,
just go to go to Las Vegas for a sheet with the comics are doing.
Then you go to La.
Then you know what they're doing and as long as they get,
that's the comics.
They work in Las Vegas all the time.
I went to some old ass joke,
Jewish joke.
They planned,
they tell it,
but Gabe Kaplan,
this old,
funny big kid looking funny.
He's a good actor,
but he,
he was,
I waste all my tests,
but I,
he told me stay there half an hour.
I mean half of half of 30 days to stay there.
So I paid my rent for 30 days and I went that night,
got up my new,
my navy suit on him and sharp is I can be born,
there's modeling clothes,
you know what I mean?
Standing around,
you know,
have a big Ole afro man.
I lost every dime I had at that fucking horseshoe casino.
I was,
I went back home crying.
So now I don't know what the Hell I'm gonna do here.
I didn't,
it drove two and a half days across the country.
And so I,
I called people in Detroit,
should I get some money?
But you know,
when you call them,
you bring long ways,
way.
Hey,
nobody got no man that people don't answer the phone.
He's all,
no,
I ain't got no money.
So I got some more borrow money from some of my friends and had to stay there
for six months till I got no money to go to la.
Well you said that,
didn't you tell me that you hit,
you did one of the slot machines and it,
it hit with three grand or something.
I had $150 left.
I saw Diana Ross.
She,
what I would do,
I would go at night and during the weekend,
during the week,
I mean,
you can go to the front of the casinos and the guy in the front.
Then he said,
I'm a comic.
I just want to sit in the back here,
watch them the comic.
And I'm gone.
They,
they let you do that shit there and ain't to anybody.
Nobody's sitting there and he's got 2000 seats in those states or something like
that.
So I had a dollar and a half left.
I saw Diana Ross,
she had a great show.
So I'm gonna Outweigh,
I said,
I'm a play this fucking money.
I ain't got just,
just be broke.
My check is coming from the unemployment.
Uh,
it'd be here another day or two.
I can go without food for a day.
He's Muslim.
He said,
Burger,
you better put some down here,
nigger.
Yes.
So I put that money in the machine.
It Rung Up,
I think it was 7,000 really?
Yeah.
I thought I fucked up something.
Oh Shit.
Now what have I done?
The guy came over,
he said,
I just got on jobs.
Just hold on sir.
I just got here.
You had struck the Jackpot today.
What Jackpot I,
he gave,
he came and pump.
Just put them $100 in my hand.
It was like a miracle.
Even like,
like Moses came down to hand me some money or something.
They was so damn.
Damn.
Money felt so good.
I went home
and packed my stuff.
I had about two more days on my rent.
I got in that car.
I got me some gas.
Joel,
you know how to have it in Vegas.
They got the little island in the middle of the street,
drove over that damn thing,
going back,
going the opposite direction.
I said,
hell with this I'm,
and when you go,
island costs are boom,
boom,
boom.
Cones come out.
Does come out and old cones.
Old stuff.
Come on the old,
on the seat,
on your hand,
your feet being dirty,
dusty,
all over it.
I drove all the way from three o'clock in the morning,
four o'clock in the morning or whatever time it was.
I drove all the way back to La and my friend let me stay at her house for about
a month.
Candy.
She was a good friend of mine.
I'm dead.
She let me do that cause that was,
that was amazing.
She lives in Beverly Hills from,
from,
from apartment motel.
I mean,
uh,
and no money eating potato worst.
I sold and I know what time me to get some money.
I'm eating a baked potato,
um,
a white potato now with the white potato and some old bread at some syrup.
And I say,
I gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
This ain't,
this ain't normal.
This is not good for the kid.
I come out here with big plans that went straight.
I went straight to her house and I got a job at Gucci and I,
I went to the comedy store and everything.
I just stayed there.
If you didn't go to Vegas,
would you have even gotten stuck?
No,
I wouldn't have got,
that's a six month.
That's a six month waiting game that you had to play because you lost the money
on ads.
Worse his county airplanes coming in and taken off course.
You can see them from my,
my door.
You see the plane and come into the Karen.
I think the name of the hotel.
The plane terminal it come in.
You see him take off.
That's all I did all day long.
He playing,
coming in as well.
Plane taking off,
playing,
coming in,
taking off and you're just stuck.
They're stuck in Las Vegas.
I've learned I deserved my monies.
So people telling you you're love money.
Yes,
I deserve every died.
I went through that shit.
Oh my God.
That car lasted another four or five years.
Really fit 65 Mustang.
That's a great car.
It a great car.
Regular gas.
I got to be some new tires.
I told you I got to be some new tires,
a case of oil and a case,
and I got,
I never got,
I got my old color TV and a bucket of Kentucky Fried Chicken
back then.
When you're trying to get up in the store,
how did,
how did the auditions go?
What did they do?
No,
you're not.
You have to go through the a potluck.
You had to go through that?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
hoping Mike the same thing to that,
but it wasn't that many commentate the close at about 11 o'clock I didn't know
comics that go on anymore.
How many comics were there?
Oh,
it must have been about 10 15 really?
And when this is,
Huh?
What?
Yours is 74 so it was at the beginning then as soon as we,
soon as Mitzi,
Mitzi just started when I was there in the beginning,
she,
she liked me.
She would get me,
she,
Johnny can come out here and work the door.
You can do anything you want.
And I said,
I need a job.
So I hustled the door.
Mitzi,
she said,
y'all better watch Johnny.
He can make some money at that damn door.
What I would do,
I was,
what'd he call Maitre d or something?
Where are you calling?
Yeah,
Maitre d.
So I would put,
uh,
a reserved signs in the front seats up there.
Reserved for the owners.
Grandmother reserved for the mothers.
Granted Mitsis father.
And so none of main movement.
I mean the main room in the other room be crowded pattern.
I said,
we sold off sir.
He said,
what does the tables up there for?
I said,
that's too onerous to grandmother be here soon.
He said with $500.
So it put me in that seat right now.
So
I would make,
I make two to 300 a night sometime.
500,000 just at the door.
Missy did.
She had me go mc and all that stuff.
Well you said 500,000,
$500 found.
No,
it wasn't that kind of money.
That's a,
that pictures her.
That's Mitzi.
No,
I know.
I recognized that picture.
Yeah,
that's when she was younger though.
Yeah.
There's a photo that was from the comedy store that was sitting around in the
backroom and Taylor boss.
That's when I,
he passed it.
Yup.
That's when I,
um,
I,
that's what I knew her when she was like that.
She was,
she's,
that's the picture right there.
Yeah.
That's the picture he used.
She was a smart lady.
She was,
let me chase my brother.
She was a whip.
She was,
she had her ways.
Yeah,
she was,
she was definitely eccentric.
But she's one of the most important people ever in comedy and comedy.
And people don't realize that.
A lot of people don't realize Mitzi was the shits.
She and that little,
it is crazy and running around.
They little baby ain't no pimping.
No polytech sees the baby.
I know.
I'm all Mitzi.
Mitzi.
And he ain't got to come back.
We don't have nobody to work the door.
I can get up and go over there.
So I'm at the door.
I got,
uh,
eight o'clock show you don't eat a clock.
So I mean what I'm seeing and,
and working the door and everything and,
and hosting the room and all that.
So I'm up there on stage.
Um,
put the,
you've got a little broke you put across the door and closed the curtain and the
beauty of people come up in the original room to come up the steps there.
You know the original room?
Yeah.
So she's in a booth taking money,
taking pictures,
taking money and get selling tickets.
She and I,
the only one they're working and the,
and the bar in the back.
So,
uh,
Mitzi,
I'm going to stay by Ba ba Ba ba Ba ba ba Ba ba now has got 10 people in the
room.
So let's go.
She said,
I'm just going here and I get them,
get there,
give me the cover and you go ahead and put the robe back.
So now I'm up to about 15 minutes.
She said about three minutes,
four minutes into my and Janny.
There are people that line come down here and letting me and you cannot do your
more,
no more material.
Come on Johnny at the Mitzi,
I'm trying to finish my ag.
Johnny,
come on.
I want to kick this money.
That's,
I learned that commercial like get that money before they turn around and go,
Oh God,
I,
that was a funny,
she sees the funniest lady.
She's a funny lady.
Let me tell you.
She was hot.
She was tough.
Mitzi was tough.
She told me,
you stick with me.
I'll make you a rich man.
I said,
Mitch,
I come here to be a comic.
I can come and be known.
Rich Man.
I'd come and be a comic,
but she's too much trouble.
To much extent.
You like sixth century,
two weeks,
century.
I didn't want to hang around too long.
The August still they're out of his mind.
See,
he's August is still there.
Are you still in there?
He said last night and I know it.
I go there and see him.
I see him all the time when they,
when I go by there,
I want to go once a year or so,
but I see our guy,
I like August.
He was,
he was telling,
he's talented.
Yes,
genius,
but he didn't,
he didn't want to lead the comic store.
He got a radio station downstairs.
He told me they have a podcast.
What's the podcast?
Yeah,
they have a podcast studio.
You bet on that studio.
Yeah,
but Mitzi Abenomic's you mutate.
I knew her in 1974 when I went over there and I noticed when I got on,
when I got on,
um,
open Mike night for people who wanted to try to become on the regular show.
Mitzi used to love impressionists.
She loved people who can do voices.
And I just realized that after about three weeks of being there,
trying to be funny,
I'm doing old Red Fox jokes.
I'm doing a book.
And then she didn't.
And then the horse race was going in and the jockey,
you ran nomadic.
My Dick,
the Horse's name was my Dick.
Just fucking Redd Foxx used to be,
he would come out and he would be so fucking funny.
Um,
so at the end,
the person come out and sing.
She loved people who saying,
uh,
Tina Turner women at Santeen utter,
she put two or three of them.
Rip Your hand each other.
They still the same song.
Jesus.
That's said Mysequel and crazy boy man.
Why?
Like Tina Turner,
she put them up impressionist,
but she loved the women call.
Do you know the women?
All of them got the same impressions,
but she put the two or three I'm on the same show.
Wow.
Same Impressions I went up to,
I started doing an impression that they,
cause I did amend Detroit on the shoulder with the nat king Cole.
Him.
She's all Johnny,
this is so wonderful.
I want you to work Friday night.
She put me on early.
He put me on some nice times and shit,
but these,
but she wanted me to stay with her on that door and emceeing help her out.
She had me click close the door,
closed the place one day.
I shouldn't be responsible for this to Nicole.
The doors lock the fucking door.
Well she's always had comics work there all the beginning,
all the time when I want it to where I wanted to work there.
Most of them comics live in their house upstairs up there and Crest Hill.
Yeah.
They lived on the hill there.
She bought all the property around there.
Yeah.
Mitzi.
Oh out on so much here on some with money when she died.
Oh my God.
The house up on this house,
the House that you know,
the house she had up on the hill there.
Crest Hill.
Yeah.
That's what the name of the House on the street.
That was the one where I'll be on comics.
Lived in it,
right?
No,
no,
no comedy live behind the comedy store up the hill.
There's one at about three or four of those.
Yeah.
She owned by three or four.
I would have to have a party over there.
The fucking party was fabulous.
I'm looking,
I'm looking at California and he'd do got the house all dirty,
you know,
they see what,
then try to make the bed and it covers thrown on top of the bed,
you know,
just throwing,
nothing tucked in.
Nothing.
Mitzi owned all that.
That guy back there.
Yeah.
I almost bought that Crest Hill House.
Yo that was for sale back in the day.
I went to look at it,
but I had a dog and I was pretty sure he's not,
he was going to get out of that backyard,
had a crazy dog.
I was like,
this is not good.
It's the one right behind the store.
Right.
I think we have it always get
the one that's up into the right.
He's got one that looks like the in the driveway.
He owns it.
I think I saw him.
I saw him the other night at the,
at the store in the parking lot and he was,
he was telling me like,
how do you use a watch them all?
My God,
I knew this
watch is as I went to run to the wall and stuff,
but maybe sit in a bed Kinison yesterday.
He's sent them too.
That's cool.
Oh,
I can't imagine leaving your fucking child with Kennison.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Kenneth Somewhat.
I told David Letterman ass,
he's just spooling.
Anybody knew what the comedy store it as really funny.
I said,
man,
you guys see this crazy dude named Sam Kennison.
And so he said,
well,
have them,
um,
have them send me the tape or something,
but give us a call on his show.
I said,
Dave,
you're going to love him,
man.
Salmon on that show.
When they judge it fell on the floor.
Sam was so funny.
And Sam,
Sam,
I said,
Sam and David,
and let him,
I want to see you on his show.
He said,
oh,
really?
He's won his first time he ever got on TV.
Wow.
And,
uh,
he was,
so,
it's always been my friend Sam.
Sam,
Kenneth always was my friend.
So I used to work Mitzi,
uh,
after a while she would get these young cats too,
like David Letterman to be the MC of the first show.
So I worked at the 12 o'clock show.
All the crazy people only show me Paul Mooney,
Sam Kennison of all,
what's the boy name?
And he talked 98,
eight,
two Elvis.
And he did,
uh,
Andy Kaufman,
Andy Kaufman.
I remember introducing him.
I introduced all of them.
He might need me.
Yeah,
no,
just say I did come to me and tell me what they want me to,
I didn't want me to introduce them,
you know?
Right.
Yes.
She ain't can come and,
and
I'm looking to do like he's got his fucking mind and
let me show you see are crazy crazy lady with the,
with the,
with the pigs.
He used bring dolls on stage and punched him.
He had a base too about like,
uh,
like remember the only,
the bare smokey the bear only you could prepare for it.
He would pull out the bear.
Only you can prevent forest sizes.
Fuck you punch the Para who is so meticulous and if people,
people would come down and just to see him,
he would go nuts.
And he was like really crazy expressions.
Unbelievably funny guy.
Like a naturally funny,
I was an east coast legend.
Yeah.
He's one of those guys.
Then he got up,
I think he had a lady broke up or something and they got to do bore.
So she moved out of,
Oh my God.
Then it was crazy.
Their employee,
they,
did you submit it?
He was,
he was the bears and all that shit that he would beat up on people whipping a
book.
Did you know Bob was,
Bob was another legend.
Another like east coast list.
Just big giant guy.
He uh,
he was like a long island legend.
So he didn't play comic store.
That mom thinking he ever made it out here.
Oh,
he didn't make it out.
Okay.
I don't know.
There's a few of them.
If he did,
he didn't stay.
I'm hanging you Bob Woods.
Oh,
where I told you I didn't know him.
Yeah,
it was a long island legend.
Really?
Yeah.
It's like back in those days like a lawn,
there was like,
he was a legend in long island around the same time.
Like those Boston guys like lending club,
they were all big time in Boston back then.
We all do.
All of Boston's got,
they were tough.
They don't have the club,
they're not well they have laugh Boston that they do local headliners.
They have Nick's comedy.
Stop your lap.
Boston does guys,
the tour there go there too.
But I mean they still have some good local talent.
And then they do like the Wilbur,
but it used to be there was like 10 if I can clubs to fucking clothes.
People believe that's what I like.
Oh,
but they,
but they got people come to you each come in late.
They come in late and they trying to get to the front when he got to see that
they take 30 minutes as you bring your ass on my parachute jumper with somebody
to jump over the divider.
I felt my last special at the wheel.
Yeah.
I love that.
I like the club chickopee Oh,
that place way out there.
Yeah.
We about an hour and a half got drive hour at hand and the club at the,
uh,
what is the mall right there to here?
They call it deal with the other club used to be,
what's the name of that club and Andover.
Is that what you're thinking of?
No.
Dramatic.
It's right there.
Right there at the mall.
You know,
stores and things.
Oh,
Fan.
Your Hall and your home.
Yeah,
the comedy connection Fan.
That's gone.
That's been gone.
That was amazing.
I wouldn't hold my full 500 it was a big place.
And you go,
you do a show there and then drive all over the chicken peak hour and a half.
Then I wouldn't have had thing and do another show on Friday.
Oh Man.
I said I can't do this and it,
then you go out to the chicken pea.
It's a Hawaiian Chinese Hawaiian restaurant.
Yeah.
And they tried to give you enough to last a whole month.
You eat.
Then they tried to give you a left to take with your up pick a go box to go
about this bulging with food they've got to get rid of.
Oh Man.
Excellent.
And the food was actually this gone.
I'm told the kids,
the kids didn't want to stay there.
I think that's what it was.
The mother and father died.
They were all on the kids didn't want to keep running a beautiful play.
And then in the Hartford,
Connecticut,
Hartford,
because Chica peers and she could be chickpeas in mouse shoes as western
Massachusetts,
Massachusetts yet.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But uh,
those were the days,
boy,
you sure long guys flight.
But I love the thing that the
airport was 10 minutes from the hotel.
I can get you ain't get you out,
give me and get it out.
There was a lot of clubs back then.
Oh my God,
I'm not a club.
It's not,
it's interesting.
It's more comics now than ever,
but I don't know.
There's more clubs.
It doesn't seem,
well they got a Lotta Lotta clubs
but they,
they,
they only book,
they don't have a,
they don't have a showcase nights.
Like you have 1520 common,
they don't have that.
They had three comics and that's all they have.
So they make their money.
It's a whole different ball game
and there's like independent shows now.
That's,
that's how it is nowadays.
Like the club circuits pretty kind of the same.
There's some new clubs,
but you know,
I hear,
I hear like a most clubs on the road.
Like they're not like the ones out here or in New York.
No,
you don't.
You don't get a chance to really showcase,
you have to either already be somebody or booking in January.
Yeah.
Be on your way type of thing.
I've been booked at Kansas.
I've been booked January 2nd or third in Kansas City.
When is,
when is it next to?
This week is 20 it'd be December 1st Jim.
I mean gentleman the be what?
Friday,
Saturday some this weekend?
Yeah.
Saturday,
Saturday in book,
six months on this bad boy.
Jesus Christ.
Six months solid.
I'm Dominic book in this club six months ago.
I'm all year for this year.
I got,
I got dates.
I wish I brought my stuff out.
UPDATES and I know I'm going to do it and December 12th to the 15th I think it
might be an Arlington,
Texas,
but I know that you get with Chris Smith and number,
they won't 10% but they book your way and you want to get to a club.
You can get that.
They will have,
they have your book,
you'll,
but you'd be in bed talking my book and books and books and books.
I'm booked too much.
Do you still enjoy the shows though?
Nope.
I've had enough.
You know,
your fans may or may not watch or listen to this.
Right.
They know.
They know that.
You know it's hard work.
You're never performing.
Yeah.
When,
whenever,
whenever I've done,
whenever I've done shows with him at the moment,
cause you know,
I'll hang out cause after every show he'll try to sell merchant and take
pictures of.
But uh,
as soon as he gets in the green room,
he's like,
Jay,
do you see how hard at work?
You see this?
You see all this I'm doing right here.
You don't know nothing.
You,
y'all know none about this hard work.
I'm like,
okay,
coping is this job.
Yeah,
it's a great deal.
Five,
six weeks in a row.
That's what I hate.
And I'm,
I'm on,
I'm on my second of five weeks,
the second,
second week now.
So I got to go next week I go to Hartford,
Connecticut,
Hartford,
Springfield.
That's why you actually fly in to that.
Then I go to Memphis.
So wait,
you said you hate it,
but what,
why don't you just stop paper?
[inaudible]
well the only time,
the only time I've ever seen him do anything outside because you know,
he's old school.
So it's one of those things where he's so used to like,
you know,
he's so used to,
he got his agents,
his managers and the,
he's so used to someone giving him work.
So that's one of the things where I'm on the road.
You're given the spots are giving up clubs and I was like,
what do you like doing?
Cause you asked that earlier.
And like the one thing that we've made between like him doing comedy and now is
we created a youtube channel for him where he does like a cooking show,
right?
So he has,
he has his own youtube channel because I do youtube and all this stuff.
I do like gaming videos and a bunch of other random stuff,
sketches and blogs.
But uh,
he was like,
well,
he's like,
I guess I got a little time off,
we can do some brand.
He's like,
maybe we can do this cooking idea.
Got,
and I said,
sure,
let's do it.
We create the channel,
we make it.
And it's called cooking for porter
people for poor people.
Because when you're hungry,
everything tastes good.
Yes.
And his channel is he John,
we'll eat a bunch of crap.
Cook a bunch of crap,
but he can kind of chicken feed and rice.
Chicken,
chicken.
We did chicken feet,
pig feet.
Ox Tail.
Uh,
chicken,
chicken feet like tough.
You gotta be,
he tried to Asian people eat.
It changes the way they eat every day.
He tried to feed it to our dog and our dog ran away from him.
So that's like a clip from the video delicacy.
It was,
that's what that was.
And then I recommend wine.
I had wine,
tall,
glass of mad dog,
2020 with the chicken.
Put them chicken feet and Thunderbird.
Thunderbird one,
number one.
You know Cisco.
Wow.
Mad Dog.
2020.
He's good at finding their own band night.
Some Mexican Salad.
Yeah.
Hanging out like an old school to get hanging out in the front with the bottled
it,
bring it down here and had to be hand the crate and they bring it up and he that
John.
Yeah.
Then you go buy some more in it.
I'm shocked that it hair go.
Hey,
you know that.
So I held,
yeah,
I helped him produce and create,
help him work on this.
Then
it gets good Putin,
you can pick fee right there in the end.
I got somebody,
Shelly threw my shit away.
I can't believe she,
she do old pig feet away.
Oh,
called light the kitchen too?
Yeah,
that's old school whose kitchen is out.
It's his house.
We have,
we bought the house next to us.
Oh Nice.
So I got the house next to me and I told the whole fence down,
guest house kitchen,
and we got on an old kitchens.
I said,
I'm going to eat that.
Don't believe that.
That's perfect.
Kitchen for local show on cooking tight and old school.
It reminds you of like growing up.
Yeah.
And it works well.
You know,
we,
I don't know,
well I think we may maybe 1215 of these things,
but people watch them.
It's just one of the things that he works on the road.
So I,
whenever free time comes around,
we used to sit back and knock them out and try to shoot him and I would edit
them and whatnot.
But now I'm busy so he has an editor so,
but you know,
I try to help them market it when it's finished.
I'm like,
all right,
post it on the social platforms,
get it out there and when that and that.
What about a comedy special?
I've done that.
If you're thinking about doing time,
you think about doing one now.
I did one.
I paid for it myself,
but how long am I my stomach to be?
I looked at her stomach and man,
oh man,
what the fuck out?
It's been $10,000 then it would have $15,000 stomach.
Horrible.
How long ago was this that you filmed on?
Did it though?
I must have been,
let's see,
about four years ago.
Four,
five years.
Did you release it?
No,
I got it.
You're talking about that one?
I thought you were talking about the one that's already done and out there.
No,
let's call.
You got to coordinate.
Yeah.
That one was from showtime.
[inaudible] you didn't release it because he didn't like your stomach.
I ain't like misdemeanor.
But you didn't,
you didn't get your way,
but you also didn't get anybody to finish editing it.
Right.
That was the guy that did they finish it?
It's all finished.
It's finished.
I don't know.
That's the name.
Uh,
what's your friend named?
It doesn't edit.
[inaudible] animation and stuff.
Gabe.
Gabe did the album.
He did the artwork,
the artwork on it.
Oh that's random.
I didn't know you fit.
I thought he you,
you always shelf there cause you watched it and you didn't like the way he came
out and then you never finished editing and posting.
My stomach came out.
Usually take that right now.
Take that right now and sell that bad boy.
I gotta look at it.
I hate to see myself,
my stomach be,
once you get somebody else to look at it,
I'm going to do that.
Just walk away.
You can cut that one and sell that one and bring that stomach down.
Chase.
It never makes any sense there.
Makes me sense.
I Hate Joe.
She'll had them here for me.
I'll get some folks.
Don't get Joe,
don't get any wind.
The baby.
Oh Oh my gosh.
A bunch of liquor on that bunch of whiskey.
Just going to shame himself later in the mirror.
There's leaving.
Let that let
that big bottle,
but you don't want to lose weight,
right?
You're not going to lose weight,
but they say you gotta stop.
We want to lose it while drinking outcomes.
They want you to stop drinking.
Yeah.
You get or take it in increments.
Do break,
dude.
Check.
I get about all day.
Drink a whole bottle a day.
Oh,
you can't get together with Ron White Dude.
He drinks.
He drinks at hard shit.
No,
I don't want that shit.
He drinking that shit key.
He drinks his own Tequila.
That's all.
But yeah,
I saw that last night.
He was in the back bar hanging out some of this together.
Yeah,
he,
he drink too much.
I know that shit getting him fucked up on stage.
I see him up there.
He Act like he can act like he's not drunk.
That mother fucker drunk and she can be man.
Ron White goes to hard.
Yeah,
he goes real hard.
He goes hard.
He goes hard at every fucking night of the week too.
Yeah.
That's tough.
Yeah,
and it's working out.
I drink.
I drink white wine Chardonnay.
Oh,
did I drink like Kevin a sending young man spread
and,
but he did get another winning.
Then maybe one more.
Then you get the bottle and pulled up to your mouth and drink.
Use Weak and didn't put it away and go to bed.
They didn't know until the next day until until the next bottle.
[inaudible] give me another suite.
There's some evidence of wine's good for you.
One little bit of bonds on bad for him a little bit to load two glasses of wine,
a date for longevity and here there you go.
How much wine is in the glass and how big the glass glass.
I said,
well what about 10 years?
He so good.
[inaudible] even better
man.
You get your grade and go to work.
You could go back and I'm in no rush.
I would say something if I had somewhere to be,
I don't want you rushing down that freeway.
Oh,
be at a dead.
Good for you.
You stepping up to being a dad to guy?
I got money at home.
I've got a couch.
It always comes full circle.
No,
I host this show.
Is it always like this?
Always?
Oh No.
People know.
I've got friends who asked me.
So your dad just,
that's who he is or does it?
Is that a character?
I'm like,
oh no,
no,
no.
He got on from being himself.
He's one of the lucky cause I shit.
Yeah.
I told,
I told him that jokingly back into it.
I was like,
you know you're lucky,
right?
He's like,
what'd you mean?
I was like,
you are your,
where are you are because you are who you are and you,
you don't have to fake it.
You just supposed to,
when you're acting,
you should be,
you should be yourself.
Yeah.
You funny enough.
Definitely be yourself.
Yeah.
I'm on the cartoon.
What did the Boondocks,
Nah.
Huh?
I didn't change my voice for the boondocks.
No,
I did all,
I did that and they coming back.
They come up,
boom,
and I was coming back.
It's a great show.
Yeah.
One of the best cartoons I've ever been.
I met the duty create and he was friends with my friend Todd.
Yeah,
I am recruiter.
that'd be beneficial.
We smart dude.
Very smart.
But like Jesus is also,
he wrote that y'all like Jesus.
Yeah.
That's another one that you're on that you had like that he like fell into.
That's the funny part.
Cause uh,
cause remember what the thing is,
I went in for that show to play one of the,
one of the leads or whatever.
Uh,
it didn't happen but I remember,
cause he's,
you know,
he's friends with Aaron and whatnot.
Aaron just called him in to do a like a one day role.
Remember?
Yeah.
He wanted me to,
he said,
John,
we need you,
your character to um,
to just do the pilot.
I'll try it,
man.
I don't feel like doing though.
Jesus.
I'm a homeless man.
Shit,
somebody I got into,
I thought it was cool.
Yeah.
He said he wants the job is yours.
I said,
well good.
So he went in to do like a,
like a guest star role and then they were like,
Dang,
he's funnier than,
than what we were thinking.
So we,
so they gave him a role that he was a seat series,
right?
You did three seasons.
We did to the air and then we finished it though,
did a third one that it hasn't aired yet.
And I use,
when I did a Hollywood shuffle,
I played a man who had lost everything.
He was homeless.
I'm sitting out there and Robert Townsend didn't have any money for wardrobe,
so I went to a secondhand store and goodwill and bought a couple of roles and
old shirt and I had a,
a t shirt of done a tour and put a pen to put it back up.
So that was,
I thought that was clever.
Uh,
so this happened 20 years ago.
I kept that outfit in my garage for 20 years and I used it on black Jesus.
Same thing I wore on the Hollywood shuffle.
Wow.
Let Shuffle up.
What was it?
A whole cake.
What's the name of that Hollywood shuffle does?
It doesn't have a shelf.
There it is.
Yeah.
He ain't got honest,
but then they,
so the,
yeah,
so then they took,
so then he wore it.
They,
they did their thing and then they were like,
well,
this thing stinks,
so we'll just recreate it for you.
They did everything over.
He got the same yeah.
Outfit,
uh,
that,
I had this,
that and look at that.
When I got done marijuana and I got my little wine looking at what whole case,
whatever happened to Robert Townsend.
What is he up to me?
He's a director now.
Just direct in different movies,
different movies and commercials and things.
He's 10 up to you.
Oh yeah.
We just stopped on tour with him.
We worked all the big places.
I remember his specials.
He always had those uh,
uh,
Hbo.
Comedy specials.
Yeah.
All human.
Wayne's did them.
Did them.
Yeah.
Robert Town's,
he's still around.
I saw the picture on my phone.
I don't know how my phone,
I don't know.
It's probably a new jacket man.
Directly lose my phone.
He does that at home.
He'll say,
hey,
I don't live with her mom.
I'm grown,
I'm married and all that stuff.
I live on my own with my wife.
He'll call me and say a JD,
you seen my,
uh,
my cameras.
I moved my camera and I don't know where it is.
I was like,
I don't live with you.
I have no idea where your things are.
He's like,
well yeah,
you know and hit my brother lives with him still side.
It's one of the things I'm like,
why did you ask Alex?
He's around or someone who's maybe at the house more often.
He's like not feeling like you might be the one who,
who might know what he's saying here cause I seen you around here.
I know you come around,
you come take my dance,
take my stuff over to get me on.
Take,
take your stuff.
I get nobody had cameras.
I bought a camera and put it over there cause I know where it is that causes
over there.
I come back,
ain't over there and I have no idea where that number because I put it over
there.
That's because you and mom and Alex and whoever else won't Romans through the
house.
We'll move things around all the time.
I don't,
I'm not there.
I'm not there to move things,
but I know what I know where I put things in there.
Then when I come back it's not there but they,
but the thing is why do you call me when I'm never there?
You know what?
It
doesn't make any sense.
You then your Mama Mama will take his stuff.
Mom,
we'll go shoot her little her stuff because she liked produces desi little
independent movie.
So she'll,
when she grabbed your cameras,
that's where they moved to.
Did you feel pressured doing stand up?
Cause this is,
you know,
actually I didn't,
I didn't want to do it.
Never really cause I got into acting and I thought that was far enough.
I was like,
I'm a dad or does that,
I don't want to,
I don't want jumping on the rest of that stuff.
And it,
acting was just kind of like on a whim and then stand up was like a dare.
A friend of mine was like,
we should,
because we back in the day,
not too long ago,
maybe early 2011 or 12.
Uh,
it's not back in the day,
but me and my boys were hanging out one night in our twenties and we just went,
uh,
we had come from a club and we drove past the laugh factory and I was like,
I was like,
you guys want to watch comedy because I don't know,
it was like 24 or something.
I was like,
I used to know that.
the owner knows me from when I was a baby.
If he's there,
maybe.
Yeah,
yeah,
Jamie Masada.
But when I,
when I bought your baby,
that's,
and that's his baby.
That's his introduction to him.
Every time I'm there.
Whenever I,
whenever I do shows,
that's his introduction for me.
He'll be like,
he'd be like,
Hey,
by the way,
I want you to send me John,
Johnny with her splints on,
I used to get in when he was banned.
I used to [inaudible] but,
uh,
we putting him on stage.
We went there,
we went there randomly one night and I'm fucking funny.
That's good.
That's a good impression.
We went there randomly one night and I remember,
uh,
the door guy,
I was like,
hey,
it's Jamie here.
And he's like,
Jamie,
who like as if I didn't know him,
I was back in there.
I was like,
ah,
you know,
the owner.
And he's like,
tell him,
uh,
JD Wetherspoons here.
I didn't think anything.
I don't use my name like that.
But then he like comes down,
he's like,
buddy,
what are you doing here?
This and that.
You're doing comedy.
I was like,
no,
no.
Me and my friends just,
we just want to watch a show.
He's like,
yeah,
come,
come in and let's get him,
get him a bottle of wine,
all that stuff.
And we're just hanging out.
Uh,
but then later,
like,
you know,
through the night he was talking,
he was like,
so you're trying to do comedy like your dad.
I was like,
I'm good.
I don't want to,
I don't care to do that.
I'm fine.
And my friends were with me.
He's like,
come on.
he's like,
you should try it.
You'll probably be funny.
Maybe even funnier than him,
buddy.
And I,
and I was like,
ah,
I don't know.
But then later on that same week,
he was like,
well,
if you ever want to come by these,
he said,
swing by through the open mic or whatever.
And uh,
and my boy Henry,
yeah,
Henry Henry was like,
hey,
we should do that,
man.
That'd be kind of funny.
You know,
maybe we be comedians.
I was like,
Nah,
I don't think so.
And then one night we just said,
I think,
I think I had someone's email from the laugh factory and hit him up and was
like,
hey,
me and my buddy are going to come by.
Maybe we can do the mic.
And then they were like,
yeah,
sure,
we'll throw you up this and that.
And uh,
my buddy Henry,
uh,
he's the one who pressured me into it.
We practiced our jokes on camera at home to see how that would look.
It was the weirdest thing.
It was so weird.
We,
we,
cause I was,
I was like getting into like,
uh,
creating content and I was going to film school and I was making like my youtube
videos,
I was doing like sketch comedy on Youtube and then I like,
we shot like a little thing.
We watched it back.
I was like,
I guess,
and then we went to the mic that night and we went,
I did it.
I was at the back end of the,
the lineups.
So I actually had a decent crowd.
It was like,
cause you know,
it starts off,
there's nobody there.
It's just comics.
And then by the time it was my turn,
it was like close to the eight o'clock show.
So it was like 35 40 people.
I had three jokes for my three minute set clean and I did it.
And they did all right.
They let people laughed and I was like,
okay,
that's cool.
Random,
you know,
and I didn't think much of it.
Henry bombed.
Yeah,
no,
but it was just one of those things where after that,
um,
right up there past the Werewolf,
what does the camera,
no,
the camp,
the cameras or the cameras over there.
You could,
if you got to go piss say to the camp,
he just said,
oh man.
But yeah,
no,
so we
did your dad is when he grip.
Well,
I got a bit about how when you just get old you just don't care.
You just don't care about what you say.
He doesn't give a fuck.
No,
not at all.
But also like that's part of who he is.
Like his part of his business is not giving a fuck.
Yeah,
pretty much.
Yeah.
Funny.
Is he though man?
I mean he's the funniest dude.
I personally know that's,
that's how I,
that's how I categorize it,
you know?
Oh,
that's,
that was my dad.
I would,
I would feel a lot of pressure.
I think it's pressure.
If I,
if I,
uh,
from the beginning always want to do stand up,
you know,
kind of like a Michael Jordan thing.
I never like it was,
it was all,
a majority of the stuff I do now is very like just happenstance.
It's like,
oh,
I just fell into this and I'm all right at it,
so I'll just keep doing it.
Why not?
When it comes to things like youtube and like I know you do unboxing videos and
gang related,
you can kind of do that now if you're a,
if you're an interesting person.
Yeah.
I don't really need much.
No,
no,
definitely not.
What the Internet now if dad came along today,
you can just didn't exist and all of sudden exists.
Didn't have this giant body of work and you just put a camera on your day like
this is my dad.
Your Dad could be fucking fair.
No,
blow up.
Yeah.
If he was like a guy that works at the post office,
so regular guy film this guy at the post office.
You're telling your friends like,
did my dad is the funniest fucking got alive and then you put a camera on him,
he would blow up.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's interesting and one that I never really think of because people always ask
me when I was growing up,
they'd be like,
oh,
how's it?
How is it that your dad,
how do you feel?
I used to get the whole time and the kids would be like,
your dads,
whoever,
blah blah,
blah,
famous this and that.
Friday the Wayne's brothers.
And I'm just like,
yeah,
but you know,
to me it's just my dad.
Like,
he's just,
he's just a goofball.
It's normal.
Like to you guys,
I get it to you guys.
You see somebody who's an entertainer and whatnot.
I'm like,
he's just,
he's always like that dude.
Have Fun.
Is he shoved his special cause he doesn't like it.
Oh,
he does funnier stuff.
He does.
Weirder stuff.
Find that special and get it out.
Oh,
I mean,
hey,
we could post it.
It's definitely,
or I could sell it and nowadays he could hit up.
I'm sure his people get hit up Netflix.
Like we have a,
we have a body of work.
People would watch it.
That's the thing.
Yeah.
He talked them into doing the new special,
I've got to get that stomach.
Got It.
Got It to you guys.
I'll have to talk them into coming back here and hitting the gym.
He does,
but he,
the thing,
the main thing is the consumption.
You know,
it's you.
All right,
let's cut back on drinking and then continue exercise and you'll see the change.
I told you,
I tried to tell him,
do a drink a every other day.
Dude,
she's interested in,
no,
it doesn't,
does it?
It sounds like he's 100% interested in drinking or,
or just enjoy,
he's 100% enjoying dead money and drinking my wine,
drinking my,
wow.
Yeah.
That's a good time.
He's back near man.
But uh,
that I live in his life and join it.
Yeah.
But that's,
that's how I got into comedy and then I just kept doing it and my friend was
like,
yeah,
no,
I'm good.
How many years were you doing it now?
I would say I'd started in 2012 but I want to say I haven't,
I didn't continue in the beginning so consistently.
I did like Mike for the first,
uh,
two years and then I started getting booked on shows and then I kind of got
lazy.
It was one of those things where everything I was doing,
uh,
like I would weigh my options if something was more of an opportunity.
I would do that over trying to get better at stand up.
But now I've been consistent for like three years,
three to four years,
just like grinding at it because I've made strides doing things and acting and,
and uh,
creating content on the Internet.
So now I kind of have a,
I guess a little bit of a cushion to just go and get good now.
You know,
cause I've been working,
so if you're doing other stuff,
yeah,
I don't have to totally rely on it.
Well,
it's one of those things where it,
because I don't have to rely on it,
it's that much more,
uh,
it's that much more of something I want to approach.
I'm like,
oh,
well now I can like have fun.
I don't feel pressured.
Not with anything about that,
but more like,
I don't feel pressured to get booked,
get booked,
get on,
get,
you know,
get a special this money.
I just feel like,
oh,
I can just take time and get good now.
Yeah.
Around
when prior was in his heyday.
Oh yeah.
That must've been something.
We,
uh,
so you were,
you were just kind of,
that was [inaudible] 74 when you were just getting their prior,
but that was,
he was,
he was already,
he was in the peak,
right.
Big Time.
Oh yeah.
And,
um,
what was I like?
It was,
he would,
uh,
you know,
when I was around the comedy store,
I was basically the host of the commies,
the one I emceed,
you know,
and I go to the door if they have a problem,
I go to the door and settle the problem and all that stuff.
Just Mitzi one.
She knew I,
I do on this stuff in,
it wasn't no fighting in them,
just being polite and stuff.
And Richard would come here and look in the back of bitchy prize in the back.
Said,
what are you doing?
Hey Richard,
how you doing?
He knew Paul Mooney,
Mooney was and David Banks,
all these,
anytime you got all these guys at the comedy store,
Richard wanted to do another album.
So what happened is,
um,
Richard,
first time I,
I saw Richard in the back,
I said,
Richard,
how are you doing spoon?
I just come by to see how you doing.
I said,
fine,
I'm doing Richard.
He never come out to see how I'm doing.
He just saying this to,
to set it up where he wanted to work on his act missing for a new album.
Um,
so I said,
Richard,
everything fine.
You want to drink?
No spoon.
I'll be finally one of those state.
And no,
no,
no.
I'm just come by and say,
how you doing?
I said,
well,
how are you doing?
How you doing?
Blah,
blah,
blah.
So I would go,
I need to go away and come back and a service.
You want anything you want to drink?
They didn't want to drink now.
So you want to drink,
he'd get up some of the red drink.
He liked all of it.
What do you call it?
Cherry in it.
It'd be like they kind of stuff and um,
so I know to go away.
I go away and they told me Richard to drive you crazy,
come back,
which is going to drive you crazy.
So I'll go away,
come back Richard,
everything are fine.
Anything else you wanted?
Someone goes,
stays in the hospital and I don't want to go to jets coming.
I say what's bony or even play with you.
Hey boom,
be Holly spoon real out and shit.
And so when I go away and come back to Richard do two minutes,
some people said Richard Pryor came by the cops.
So he said,
sure.
I go up and do it to me.
He said,
when am I going?
I said,
going on,
went up this guy,
get off you.
I put you on right now.
And he'd go up there and do two and two hours.
Then he'll sit and he'll call,
he'll have,
his secretary called me the next day.
So thanks for helping me get on stage,
helping me get on stage.
He had to be pushed on stage.
That's a weird,
yeah,
that's amazing.
Anyway,
but Robin Williams,
Richard would do like two hours,
but is that an hour and a half hour and a half regular thing?
Huh?
Who his album,
you know he got,
yeah,
he do his whole outfit and then he had his writers in the back of Moonee would
bet they're writing him,
give him,
coaching him on stuff to say,
you know that stuff.
He had all that and then he would have,
or three weeks in the original room where he would work every night.
He'd come home every night.
Wow.
It ain't like some comments give,
you know,
get too high to come,
can come back and he'll be bad at every night.
And so Mitzi put me on the show with him.
So I would open this show and do 45 minutes and the rich would come on and do
what I want to have.
And then we moved to the main room after about three,
about a month in divisional room.
We moved to the main room.
That's when the man and he would draw.
So miss will make so much money.
He would draw so many fucking people.
Old Holes ain't been out on the street.
Loans
for college,
first coat of Fur,
fake fur coat on pink and yellow and shit.
Then
he would have in the main room,
he would have,
oh my God,
he had Mick Jagger.
Uh,
what's the name of the board that,
uh,
what's his name?
Willie Nelson.
I hadn't,
I thought Willie Nelson go up on the stage and sing a song and the original
room.
Really?
Yeah.
I said really?
You got you.
You could be,
I got it.
Cause you got this single song.
God Love Willie Nelson.
He was so good.
He's still around though.
And he,
he's,
I'm scared to do that.
I'm so nervous.
Don't be nervous,
but he's fucking people.
He went up there and st one of his son,
boy,
uh,
was,
that was,
that was a thrill for me.
So then we moved to the main room,
but I,
but I would kill every night in,
in a,
in an audience like that.
I'm going to stand up patient because I would do Mathis and I learned from
Detroit and Nat King Cole and them I would do met Johnny Mathis and my last bit
and I would do l green just before that.
Um,
and I,
and I w
I saw Al Green,
uh,
throw roses out until the ladies one time I was at Intel when does it to this
theater down anyway,
he with roads and he hand wrote it to the ladies.
So I,
when I was working at the comedy store and I'm in front of each,
I would get done the lines handled from the ladies and the lump sum lady did
exactly what I want her to say.
She said,
Al Green give us roses.
I said,
well you lucky these ain't plastic cause I ain't got no damn money.
I go home and watch TV so I can get them back to you tomorrow night.
And I did that and doing then Jay,
Johnny Mathis is just impressions and I added to my act because there a lot of
ladies out there and they love that shit.
And I got the women through the rows and back at my feet.
I said,
damn,
this shit is cool in the motherfucker.
And Richard told me,
I said,
Richard,
everybody said bitches,
you should take spoons on the road with you.
You,
you're going on the tour.
He said,
Oh,
I love you spoon,
but you too funny.
I ain't going.
I can't have you out there on the road with me.
He said I was too funny for him.
Wow.
And he took a fighter's,
you know,
find his hit the shore if find this would do impressions and stuff.
He doesn't all impressions.
So he took him on the road.
He told you,
you are too funny spoon you too funny.
I love you,
but you two down in front of you open for me.
I don't want it to be where I had to work that damn hard on women back at my
feet.
Boy dandelions.
That's a letter.
That was a great compliment,
but I have to do the billboard of the comedy store at Richard Pryor and John
Witherspoon.
Wow.
I had it somewhere in my phone.
Yeah.
You,
you,
uh,
I think mom posted it and then as she did,
then I,
uh,
I think I repost,
I helped you repost it on your igg story and then the comedy store screenshotted
it and posted it.
No.
Did they?
Yeah,
they did that.
They did that like a month or two ago.
Wow.
Good.
David's prayer had his own TV show.
You know,
he's on NBC at eight o'clock and he was so fucking high boy,
Richard Richard.
I knew we weren't gonna last.
That's it.
We only did four shows.
They were scared to 22.
Richard was too fucking high
and oh man.
What was he high on?
Cocaine and [inaudible] and stuff,
you know,
but I didn't have no money.
I probably would've gotten me something if I had some money.
I ain't no damn money.
I'm making this little $400,
$400 that they gave me for this week.
He said,
Yo,
y'all ain't making no money.
But I'm making $250,000 a show.
I told him,
damn.
Wow.
He's making not much to see.
There you go.
Look in there.
Richard Pryor and John with her spelling.
Wow.
Lj,
the year we should have the year that be 77.
That's amazing.
77,
but I know Richard,
we used go his house every Sunday.
We used to be at his house every Sunday and,
and he had um,
he had um,
a barbecue.
Had people he had a little bit,
he got a gym boxing gym.
Where you box tennis court,
Swimming Pool.
Uh,
he had four,
about four acres over there and I remember,
was it,
where was it?
It's on Parthenia.
Their house there was for sale recently for about 4 million.
But uh,
I don't think people realize that Richard Pryor live in it.
They don't want to do,
they called the EAP caught on fire over there.
Whoa.
Limited time.
You got caught on fire.
He goes,
that house.
It was in the House Day.
Fuck.
I would love to own that.
Something like Northridge or something.
Part of the day.
It's,
it's on Partina.
We used when I'm doing [inaudible],
it's right down the street.
Don't feel,
yeah,
we just go over there every Sunday.
Imagine owning Richard Pryor's old house.
Uh,
I don't want to go in their book and that spirit might hit me up.
He on five on run past the swimming pool,
you know that he was,
he came days must have been crazy there.
Oh Man.
And what's amazing about this is so cold boy,
when the stuff got on radio that Richard Pryor is in hospital in critical
condition,
he and from Burns from pipe that blew up.
Um,
his family went there and stole all of his,
his people that he probably never seen in emceeing in years.
Jumped over that damn you had this huge fence and stole all these watches and
everything.
All this stuff taken out of his house.
Then he say he's gonna so by they jumped back over the fence and put it back.
No,
what?
They jumped back on the fence with this stuff.
They put it back.
Yeah,
they put it back.
They Richard Price.
You won't steal his stuff.
You,
you've been borrowed from him for,
but 20 years now all of a sudden you're going to steal his watch.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
It's a hard to be had so much fun over there.
And Sammy Davis Jr would come there every Sunday and the limousine and a Tuxedo
when Yeley we got shorts on.
You know your raggedy short.
You can find old tee shirt.
We playing basketball.
Send me,
come at the high mind.
Hi.
The semi go put some fucking shorts on your lane.
Was He back then Sammy?
Yeah.
Oh I bet he weaved.
This was 76,
so he must've been while he was young then because he died about 61 62 63.
He must've been in his fifties,
forties,
and fifties.
Tuxedo Tuxedo in a limousine.
Imagine being the funny guy who gonna fall.
But Sammy Davis Jr pulls up in a Tuxedo.
Oh Man.
Times have a limousine.
We all said it was only in basketball.
We also fucking,
uh,
we also fucking raggedy,
stinking weird and play ball all day long.
70 was passing behind my
Sammy Rome house phone.
Damn.
Come on.
Play some ball with us.
Send me.
But we did that.
It was a nigger look at Sharpie is wow.
Look at the bell bottoms.
Oh yeah,
that's a day yesterday brother.
Wow.
You played tennis.
Did he?
Yeah,
he played tennis.
Yeah.
And basketball.
We playing ball bitches.
He checked me and grabbing my Dick,
Richard.
No basketball.
I got checked in.
I checked.
The only way I know
back off me Bro.
Ugh.
Even funny man.
So when you were around,
when Kennison came by,
when he first saw you first started working there,
that was,
yeah,
he was a big shift,
right?
That was a,
no one had seen anything.
Anybody like him before.
Oh no dive.
Even since,
yeah,
he was a,
Gary sold each one.
Dude.
What's so funny,
one time he,
he,
he bought some Chinese food with a hat on his head with a alone coat on.
There's some big sunglasses and ate it in front of this uh,
change Korean store just standing there when he's outside standing and want to
do.
And I did.
Oh,
fucking fucking Sam.
Why was he doing that?
That's crazy.
[inaudible].
He had the same thing
on this date at the comedy store.
He will be upset with his sunglasses on and he would have Chinese food or Korean
food and he sit there and eat and tell some jokes and go back onstage at the
minimum individual rooms.
That's fine.
I've seen him crazy.
I've seen some crazy people in the original room by enabled,
they were funny what a comedy store has a lot of history.
Oh my God.
Mitzi.
Let them do it.
It was so nice to people.
She was brilliant.
Let me tell you something.
She knew to let the comedians run the place.
She was smart,
joke around about,
but then sailing a misfit toy.
She goes,
you know what,
she's,
I tried to tell her,
I said,
Mitzi give the comics $5 to buy some eggs and bacon on the way home.
She didn't want to do that and at the end of this ain't nothing.
This is cotton.
This is their college,
missy.
Anybody paid to get in here?
You better go on and get these people ain't gonna.
You're gonna.
They gonna mess up your room.
And then when she went to a big stink with the right,
the right medium for the strike,
big stink.
And then you had some people that will see,
you can tell some people crazy.
Uh,
what's the name jumped off the roof of the,
of the jail.
I had house hold is his name.
I knew his name.
I knew the kid.
I used to introduce some all the time.
Uh,
shit,
I don't have her name right now,
but uh,
to meet you just give him something,
you know,
so they think that they're,
they've done something.
Most of them drove by here and,
and they all want to succeed.
They want to like,
they succeeded at something.
She's paying us,
she's paying us for,
for four eggs,
but she didn't want to do with me up.
Now I don't know how much they get.
Today happens you get,
you don't know how much you can do.
You get regular,
so you get paid.
It wasn't get a percentage of what the take is for the doors.
Good in the main room.
So if the main room sold out,
you can make money.
And then they used to do that bar.
I think the argument they'd been doing that for a long time.
They five bucks.
Yeah.
I think get four or $500 in the,
in the and in the main room.
In the main room you can make some money.
Yeah.
But for guys like us,
it's more important as a place to exercise.
It's like a joke.
Yeah.
I did two shows there last night.
I used to love the work,
the uh,
and the uh,
with Richard Pryor.
Boy.
Wow.
What a wonderful the ordinances on every note.
Everything you say,
they're right there.
Oh,
I'd imagine.
Oh they must have realized too.
Cause before when you think about like real giant famous comedians before,
prior.
That's like a tiny handful of them.
Nobody like him.
And he'd say he was just one of one.
Then I remember Redd Foxx used to come through there and I want to get me in
down double look up.
I say a and a coke and I ain't paying or none of that shit.
[inaudible]
red was so funny.
Boy Read my man read.
I bought it and I was at a gas station stop one day,
you know,
in the little stores and had cassette tapes of Richard Pryor performing live at
Red Foxes Club,
uh,
Red Fox at a club.
They just had a recorder and he's just fucking around.
Oh yeah.
You can tell he's ranting and raving.
He says hi.
Just laughing and talking shit on stage.
Like it's not prepared material.
Half of it.
It was amazing what a character.
Redd Foxx said,
boy,
he wouldn't pay his taxes.
So the government came there one night when he only people in the room took
everything,
everything.
Went to his house,
took everything.
He took a ring on his finger and he took his shoes.
They took it and they never made chicken raw to cook in the oven.
And so he,
they shut him down.
It's the place she had,
I think is on La Sienna because somewhere it was in la.
Yeah,
La yet.
Um,
so he crying.
Oh God.
He called Sammy Davis.
He called [inaudible],
they call it [inaudible].
They took her everyday now own.
I worked so hard to be who I am.
I do.
I just,
I only texted any of that bad.
They took everything.
So Frank Sinatra and Sammy Davis junior and some other other friends,
uh,
went to his club and work two or three weeks every night.
Two shows,
sold them out to get enough money to pay,
get his taxes and get his club back.
He was so happy to everybody's,
Oh my God,
I want to thank you for doing this for me.
Oh,
please just take my dick,
my,
my may hug.
Let me just hug you.
Hugging everybody.
So they all went on these type of ways with Fox.
Still didn't pain.
Fucking Texas.
No.
Come in and came and lean on his A's.
You son of a bitch.
You do.
They want friction out the name.
But I coming back now,
see,
oh my God,
we'll pay taxes again.
He paid no taxes.
Was this before or after Sanford and son?
It was before.
And I bet,
I don't think he paid after San,
he believed in Plano,
Texas.
My money
pay my taxes.
Uh Damn.
Yeah,
you got to pay him.
I got,
I had tax problem that we had an apartment building in Beverly Hills.
I own apartment in Beverly Hills.
I said,
well,
I'm doing good.
I just ran my car past dancing.
That's my place.
And I swear the taxes got bad.
If something happened to me and they took that fucking place,
I had to sell it.
I didn't take it.
I to sell it.
I hate that need today.
I hate that you hit all that money you missed,
aren't ya?
Oh God.
Well just a rad pass and look at the place and,
and uh,
and we'll get some lady called,
uh,
we,
we had him push the person to clean up the place all the time.
Sheet manager of the hotel.
And so my wife out there watering the grass and stuff.
I mean,
she called the police,
uh,
called him and said,
there's a black lady out here watering the grass and we don't recognize her.
And somebody who was a tenant,
are you talking about the manager Senate called the managers and he said was
probably the owner.
It was Angela.
I do it.
That's funny.
I used to go back there and sit cause they had the wash machine and dryer
outside.
Uh,
in the back you need the parking lot.
So he was,
it was outside but it was in enclosed.
I sit out there,
boy it would be so quiet back there.
I said,
boy,
this beat Detroit.
Them don't chase my ass down the street and this,
this is much better.
I got a pocket full of money.
I ain't want to leave
like a pocket full of money.
Want to leave?
Ain't leave.
[inaudible] got my ass out that damn place.
You need a,
you need to make a podcast.
Call it the pocket full of money podcast.
I thought about doing one.
Huh?
Have you thought about doing pause?
What does that,
that's what we're doing right now.
I don't want this to be on the air.
You can't,
he's,
he's in.
He's in a different realm,
Joe.
But you can sell out everywhere.
If he did that guarantee you money off selling fall.
[inaudible] told me that somebody took,
oh I don't want it to comic club.
I actually got anywhere
comical meant club.
I don't have trouble with those theaters.
Uh,
if I'm on the I,
they don't pay enough money,
you may sell out.
I go up there and do,
I mean I was,
you had to do for podcast or,
yeah,
let's do whatever you want.
You could do,
like,
you could do it every time you're on a plane talking to your phone.
Where are you talking about?
How much time do you do on the podcast or the theater or are you talking about
pot?
Pot came as much time as you want.
If I was in the theater and I'm doing a pocket,
you got to sit at a thing like this and you're not in it.
See,
I knew,
I knew he crossed it.
I was like,
what?
No,
no,
no.
He's saying,
he's saying can you sell out theaters by yourself?
That's what he asked you.
I doubt that.
Okay,
so we established that you sell out clubs,
but then he was saying if you were doing a podcast,
kind of like what we're doing right now,
that's what this is.
Uh,
you could,
as you build up the podcast,
you could be promoting it and recording it.
You wouldn't have to do it in a theater.
You can do it at that comfort of your own home.
You can do,
you can set it up like this,
just like this.
And then you,
you become popular.
Sure.
I mean you've got popularity behind you,
so I'm sure people want to hear it.
100%.
Yeah.
Just when I came into this,
you're gonna want to hear it.
Yeah.
I have,
I have a podcast with Paul,
me and me and my brother Paul.
We have a protocol,
the JD and Paul cast.
It's just me and my buddy and we talk like video games and video games,
technology,
whatever your current current events and also like movie.
We'll do a little mini movie reviews on it.
Kind of set up.
Do you have,
do you have a microphone?
I'm like,
I'm like a tech dude,
so I have everything.
I,
my,
my office at my house is a,
it's like decked out with a bunch of stuff.
I brought him over there recently to help me.
I,
I get him to do videos with me just because it's like they're funny and I don't
care.
And like let's just make something random.
Because the other day we played mortal Kombat and I had him,
I had him react to the fatalities.
So I was like,
that's a funny video.
My Dad reacts to mortal combat fatalities and literally we're watching it.
Literally he's just like,
Oh man,
look at her head,
go left and rang.
No,
this so amazing.
Yeah,
that stuff is,
and that's on my gaming channel,
which is run.
Jd run on youtube and stuff is too serious for me,
but like our,
our podcast.
But we've also,
we've,
I've also had him play Vr,
so because he wanted to play VR robot,
he's like,
do you have seen you doing the virtual reality?
Let me see.
You try to,
so we did the one with the shark attack,
that's another one.
This one wasn't even a game.
It was just like a tutorial.
Like you just put it on and live through the thing and it's like a deep ocean
dive and he was tripping out.
It's like this shot I shot a shotgun.
Sharks.
Yeah.
Sharks in his face and he's screaming about it.
He's like,
he's like,
and mind you,
there was a point in the video,
uh,
where he's,
he's not talking but he's shaking and I thought something bad was,
I thought something's happening.
I'm like,
Dad,
are you good?
He was trying to,
he was like trying to kick and or strangle the shark,
which was virtually in front of me.
He was like,
he was like,
he was like this and I'm like dad.
And he just yells out at the shark.
He's like,
fuck Outta here.
[inaudible] her name was Shelley was standing in the cage.
The cage take you down all your,
yeah.
I then bought him a playstation four to play the game at his house and I don't
know any of that stuff.
Your,
your son took it.
My brother took it cause my,
cause my brother uses
it for Netflix.
He just watches the play.
There we go.
That's looking at him.
Look at him going crazy.
Look.
Yeah,
he's bugging and that's me and my brother were going,
we're like dying laughing about it and dumped it over my head.
Yeah.
Looking back on my neck,
my neck.
Oh my God.
Oh Man.
This is the show.
Yeah.
No,
but it shows you and him.
We,
we've,
I mean we,
I tried to create stuff with them all the time just because it's random and
funny.
Back in the day I probably didn't do it cause people,
it's one of those things where,
uh,
it wasn't a huge deal.
But now this Washington's best,
some video titled Jamie for people.
My Dad freaks out playing with Er.
Yeah,
the Youtube Channel is away.
It's on,
it's on my channel,
which is youtube.com/run JD.
Ron is the name of the channel is cramping from laughing.
You guys,
you guys got to see it in its entirety.
So goofy dude,
you do it once a week.
Get together with your dad.
Just go pick them up,
grab them,
make it real easy.
Bring in place.
You do show with them once a week.
That's,
it might have to do an audio thing.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
cause I had,
yeah,
the setup Tang,
yeah.
Goes to audio.
Audio.
This,
this here.
We'll pocket.
We got finally,
we got to find the name.
We've got to find the name.
Finished packing.
All right,
let's wrap it up and get to them.
Joe,
he's the King of complainant,
man.
I'm trying to tell you I was stressed.
I try to tell them all the way over here.
I'm like,
hey man,
don't be weird.
Let's just hang out.
Enjoy Joy.
Come on,
I'm,
I'm gonna do my thing duty.
But if I got to do my thumb and do my thing,
I got to pee.
I gotta take a dude.
If I gotta take a shit,
I'm going to take a shit.
Oh my God.
It's like these muscles are cramped up.
You a goof ball man.
Anyway,
you ain't got no,
you ain't got no couth where you're cool.
Thanks John.
I appreciate you.
They ain't no cool.
What is cool?
It's nonsense.
Lesser mortals.
Yeah,
he's a clown.
I appreciate you,
sir.
Thank you very much for Joel here,
man.
Where are we at?
Where are we at Jamie's place for sure.
Yeah.
That's probably the only first man,
man.
Yo,
you're a little kid.
I was a little kid.
I was like,
yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
Back in the day,
man,
I was about 60 wow.
And what did my 15 years ago?
14 years ago,
probably somewhere out there.
Maybe more than that.
Even.
Maybe more than,
yeah,
more than that.
When I met you.
Yeah.
Walked late fifties yeah,
I probably would do doing the Wayne brothers or something like that.
Yeah,
you were.
Yeah.
That's probably what it was.
If you were on 40 frown.
Yeah.
I'll be doing Friday doing Friday the Wayne's brothers.
All that.
Yeah.
It's been a long time.
My phone,
man.
It's amazing.
Thank you.
You're hilarious.
It was a pleasure.
Yup.
That's what we're doing.
A podcast.
Just,
we've got to come up with a name.
Let me know.
I'll have you back out.
We could just talk to pension debt.
Oh,
we'll figure it out.
You're your Twitter handle,
your Instagram,
all that jazz at Jd Wetherspoon everywhere.
And if you want to see those gaming videos,
it's a,
it's a run JD run on youtube.
That's me.
And then you got your joints,
uh,
at John Witherspoon.
Oh man,
this is so hard.
You understand?
He thinks he's in a simulation.
I can't,
he might think he's in the matrix.
The Internet is the Internet.
The Internet is crazy to him.
But yeah.
Thank you gentlemen.
John would be John Witherspoon as to where you're cooking show.
Is that on Youtube?
Just type in John with his phone on the Internet.
Jd Wetherspoon if you want to see some goofy stuff.
We're here.
Thank you gentlemen.
Thanks for having this job.
Wow.